dès que j'enlève mon pouce
l'objet pleure c'est le champ de fleurs
partir à la découverte des objets et des
techniques artisanales du 15e siècle
c'est l'enjeu de ce premier rendez-vous
de la Madeleine un cadre idéal celui du
château de la Madeleine construit en
1483 achevreuse pour rendre l'expérience
vivante des médiateurs vêtus en tenue
d'époque présente dans ses murs leurs
techniques
monnayage taillage de pierre et même
calligraphie l'artisanat est à l'honneur
on souhaite élargir les publics
développer la fréquentation et proposer
à chacun une réelle expérience de visite
en plus évidemment de la découverte de
ce magnifique site mais ce qui nous fait
nous vibrer encore plus c'est de
d'essayer de leur vraiment de des
passeurs de savoir et de et de les de
leur faire découvrir la vie quotidienne
des gens au plus proche de ce type de ce
que ça pouvait être dans la réalité
conçu par le département des Yvelines
l'immersion dans cette forteresse du
Moyen-Âge permet à tous d'en connaître
davantage sur les temps anciens j'ai
trouvé ça super chouette que il propose
des ateliers sur les artisanat pour que
les enfants puissent le découvrir
pour découvrir sous un autre angle la
vie médiévale le château de la Madeleine
propose d'autres rendez-vous ouvert à
tous et gratuits alors à vos agendas les
27 et 28 mai découvrez la médecine du
Moyen-âge les 10 et 11 juin prochain
partez à la rencontre des chevaliers
lors de la guerre des centres et le
week-end des 7 et 8 octobre les Vikings
vous attendent